nous sommes devenus une nation de 66
millions de procureur
[Musique]
et cette stratégie elle assume
aussi la part de risque et d'erreurs et
je le dis parce que ce qui va avec la
défiance française c'est aussi cette
espèce de traque incessante de l'erreur
c'est pas comme ça qu'on fait face aux
crises ou qu'on avance et donc chacun
fait des erreurs chaque jour celui qui
ne fait pas d'erreur ou celle qui ne
fait pas d'erreur c'est celui où qui ne
cherche pas ou qui ne fait rien ou qu'il
eut mécaniquement fait la même chose que
la veille l'usagé du masque en
population générale n'est pas
recommandée et n'est pas utile s'il y a
une deuxième vague qui arrive est ce que
cette fois ci nous serons prêts oui nous
serons prêts la france n'a pas à rougir
de sa stratégie globale de lutte contre
cette pandémie
[Musique]